Film Courage: Let’s go back to the writing
process with you and Melissa.
So what was going on in your life when you
started coming up with ideas for ALL I WANT?
I know it was her idea for the story initially,
right?
West Liang: Yeah.
I was in the middle of finishing a full-length
play and I was in the middle of workshopping
that play because it was a story of what I
wanted to work out and was doing that.
And so when she first approached me my mind
was really in another story in terms of my
writing.
And as an actor, I was taking myself out of
things a little bit because of whatever reason.
I’d just gotten disenchanted with the process
of an actor’s life.
So I started writing something to produce
and direct and when she approached me there
was something about the story.
Both Melissa and I are big fans of ensemble
movies and so that was our initial kind of
connection, where we are fans of ensemble
films.
And I also think that the theme of what we’re
trying to talk about in this movie is a really
important theme for me and for her this idea
of people in the modern American city right
now (I feel like, at least certainly in Los
Angeles) there is kind of this undercurrent
of stress and anxiety and depression that
people don’t talk about.
Film Courage: You see it, though.
You feel it.
West Liang: You feel it.
You bump up against it.
And I’m not talking about clinical disorders
of anxiety or depression or things like that.
I’m talking about the garden variety kind
of weight of anxiety, of stress, of depression.
And that is for me feels like a very un-talked
about area of modern life.
People who are trying to figure out - what
kind of jobs they want to have?
Do they want to switch careers?
Do they want to get married and have kids?
Are they happy with their partner?
With their families?
And I think thematically that was something
that we both wanted kind of pull apart and
examine.
That’s the wonderful thing about this film
is that it’s got amazing performances across
the board.
There is amazing technical prowess in terms
of cinematography and editing and composition.
I’m certainly proud of my work as a director,
Melissa and I are very proud of it as producing
partners and someone who collaborated to make
the script happen but thematically I think
it’s an interesting thing to talk about
for the audience that we don’t already talk
about right now.
Film Courage: I know it’s taboo because
nobody wants to get too heavy, but I sense
it living in LA as long as I have, I’ve
seen the change and I don’t know if it’s
because it’s busier here.
And on a side note (and we can take this out
if you don’t want to talk about it) but
where you live (and I won’t say where it
is), but it’s removed…
West Liang: In the Hollywood Hills (smiling).
Film Courage: Well it’s removed from Hollywood
and you have a lovely place here by the way.
And I can see why you would want to be here
because it’s not part of the industry but
you are so creative and you do produce things,
you don’t just talk about them (you have
a body of work).
Why choose some place that’s not in the
heart of the industry?
West Liang: Well it wasn’t initially by
choice, it was based on so many different
factors in terms of where you want to put
yourself, where do you want to make your nest
per se oftentimes when you don’t have all
the resources you want to have.
But I think as a result of all these different
factors forcing me to make a decision I’m
able to kind of have a home that feels a little
bit, kind of on the outskirts of the hub of
Hollywood.
And I think that gives me a certain sense
of I don’t know whether it’s distance
or peace from it or whatever…having some
quiet time to work on whatever you want to
work on.
Film Courage: So you don’t feel that pull
to be in that sort of The Hub?
West Liang: No, no, no.
I mean not anymore.
I think when I first moved down to LA it was
really important for me to be surrounded by
where everything is happening and that was
exciting for many years and I think now it’s
kind of nice to sort of be around that, have
access to that, but also have the ability
to tuck yourself away and not be surrounded
by that.
Film Courage: Are you more creative in the
daytime or nighttime?
West Liang: Definitely in the day time, yeah
I think so.
I am more of a morning person.
And I don’t know if Melissa has ever complained
about it?
I don’t think so but every time we would
have meetings I would always be like “Let’s
do it at 8:00 in the morning.”
And she was like “Yeah, sure.”
I think that’s also kind of interesting,
too.
Because as a side note I’m collaborating
on another project with someone else who is
a night person.
In some interesting ways, that’s kind of
caused some friction.
Because after 8:00 p.m. my mind just relaxes
and starts to think about other things.
And I kind of want to eat and I kind of want
to watch a movie, I want to just go to the
gym and do nothing.
And during the day I’m really productive
and for this other person, it’s the opposite.
Film Courage: Interesting.
West Liang: It would be interesting to take
a tally to see where are, are they a morning
or a night person and also their collaborators
are they the same or opposite?
What are you?
Are you a morning creative person or?
Film Courage: I would say I get much more
done after a cup of coffee and in the morning
and then past a certain point I’m just done
and I don’t…nothing is worse than being
behind a computer when it’s like 2:00 a.m.
and I can’t see straight and that’s not
where my best self lies.
So I get that.
But I know there are some people that come
alive at night.
I think we’re all just hardwired differently
and there is no right way.
I mean you hear of these entrepreneurs that
get up at like 4:45 a.m. and they take a cold
shower and they’re ready and they’re doing
a wheatgrass smoothie.
And that’s great.
I don’t think I can do 4:45 a.m.
Everyone has their own process.
But then there are some people who fool themselves
and that’s the trick I worry about.
West Liang: I definitely think that the footnote
to that question is really like when do your
inspirations come and for me they come all
over the place and at any time but oddly it
comes at night often as well.
I just think that you let it sit.
Inspiration comes to you, ideas come to you
and you let it sit around in your head and
you can’t really actively do anything about
it, I just sort of let it sit and then I will
try to actually execute on the idea during
the day.
Film Courage: Did you grow up in a big city?
West Liang: I grew up in the suburbs of the
San Francisco Bay Area.
I mean I worked and played in The City but
suburbia.
LA is unique in some ways in a sense that
there are so many ambitious people coming
here to do what seems to me like kind of an
impossible kind of task of making your living
as an artist.
And so I think maybe with that, maybe where
the country is or expectations or all these
kind of different things cause anxiety in
the city.
Cause anxiety in people who are expected to
get married or expected to make a certain
amount of money in their jobs or expected
to do certain things and how that bumps up
against what you are able to do.
Film Courage: I think the money part is a
huge factor in this city.
West Liang: Yeah…being able to afford where
to live.
It’s tough which is why for me I wanted
to really explore that in this movie.
This movie is very much about friendship,
it’s about family, love, modern love and
life and all those kind of things.
There’s a lot of humor in this story, there’s
a lot of fun moments in the story that I think
the audience can really enjoy.
They can see themselves and their friends
and their family in their characters in this
movie but I think at the same time it also
starts conversation about that, about anxiety.